st louis will turn it over to the lefty
kim and he'll get the start today
yeah he's been getting better like we
said
at the open and they need a big start
for him today this is a big game
swang in a miss struck him out in the
first of the afternoon
for kim
kept hitting in the books and there's no
score
they'll face aaron nola who's two and
one at era of 2.84 this will be his
fifth start at busch stadium
her ball swung out and fouled tipped and
a strikeout for nola at a one two three
bottom of the first inning well that was
the best pitch he's thrown this entire
inning
trying to check did he go
he did says james hoy's second strikeout
for nola
he didn't even run hard now that's the
part of it too that's
exasperated
and a call strike three three straight
strikeouts for nola two away here in the
second
you see this inning command a lot better
for aaron
starting to hit those quadrants
good luck with that one
that's the one he throws to the left
off the glove of sosa and into left
field a base hit for mccutcheon
the fourth hit of the day
the phillies with their lead off man on
they've had base runners in every inning
thus far against kwon young kim that's
the slowest curveball kim's thrown this
year
70 miles an hour rolling in there and
that's a big test
for andrew mccutchen if he goes out and
gets it it's a rollover it's so awesome
to watch guys that really care
ground ball left side arenado will get
the lead man get the lead man keep the
double play in order take a man out of
scoring position brings up jt rio muto
no score third inning and the 1-0 swung
on hit well to right williams back into
his right this is not going to get
theirs it's going to split the
outfitters and go to the wall bum on his
way to third they're waving him home and
the relay to the plate there will be no
relay as the double by jt ramuto will
score alec balm from first and the
phillies take a one to nothing lead
what a job right there goes down and in
with the fastball for ball one
and then change up away just what you
would typically do this ball's down in
the zone and he stays on it and hammers
it
this is a rollover pitch that they're
hoping for and he goes and
postures up
two balls one strike
runner goes pitches a strike throw to
second base is also a strike he's out
what a throw by jt and a quick tag from
nick maton two outs
why
i don't think he had a good job
but it's a breaking ball too and
you know so quick from glove to hand for
jt and
a perfect throw
jt's taking over that man was the best
kid thrower at baseball as far as the
catchers go
line drive out to right field going back
on it is roman quinn reaches up at the
last moment makes the catch
and the inning is over no runs one hit
goldschmidt has struck out today 0 for
one
popped up
outside of first
hoskins
has room and makes the catch
that's a big out right there
two outs especially one pitch
huge
reese has had a ton of chances hasn't he
down there on those pop out remember
about one game he ran down there what
four times and never caught one they
were too far out of reach
the 3-2 swing and a miss mccutcheon
strikes out
one gone in the fifth inning that's
three strikeouts for kim leading to alec
bohm bowman has been on with a single
and a force play ground ball high
fastball struck out mccutcheon that
fastballed 88 from kim
while hoskins
holds the bat high over the right
shoulder the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss
a changeup strikes out hoskins
two strikeouts in the inning four in the
game for quang young kim and halfway
through the game the phillies lead one
nothing
you know
with when aaron's going right it could
be anything but i i think you got to go
fastball oh it goes curve go there do
that yeah swing it to miss five
strikeouts for noah
who's now retired the last six
and the one-two pitch to kisner
sticks the bat out fly ball shallow
center and it drops in for a hit herrera
kept it in front kisner trying for two
and save its second base
the hustle of andrew kisner and he's two
for two tell you what
that young man at center field covered
some serious ground didn't he
got a pretty good jump too
i thought he was going to catch this
ball i think that if he leaves his feet
and he can leave his feet he's got a
really good chance of
catching that ball
swag and a miss
threw one curve after another and gets
his sixth strikeout
there are two outs
and they're going to walk him
intentionally you know you would assume
a pinch hitter is coming up for kim
cardinals will pinch it with matt
carpenter here for kim and so runners at
first and second and matt carpenter will
be the pinch hitter go ahead run it
first base
the one pitch
carpenter with a drive into deep right
it's at the wall
and it's gone
pinch it three-run bomb carpenter
3-1
st louis
i thought quinn had it at first
he was oh so close
carpenter off the bench
sends a jolt through bush
told you it's been coming he's getting
closer
keeping his weight back
that front foot locked in
and
wow
oh
he did have it for a second if he
catches this ball
we might need the defibrillator for
carpenter right now
so here's andrew mccutchen catches one
for three today down three to one in the
seventh the pitch
swung on line towards left center that's
going to get down for a base hit and
rolling for the alleyway meiton will
score easily mccutcheon on his way to
second he'll be there sliding with a
double and an rbi double at that as
he's cut that lead in half it's now
three to two st louis
i'm gonna have a couple guys step up
right here and two doubles in this
inning and this one from kutch salad
balm who has a base hit in three plate
appearances a run scored and he's got
the tying run at second base how big
would that be huh
back toward the middle off the mountain
into center field mccutchen's around
third he's being held there he went
through the stop sign the throw to the
plate is cut off he scores it's an rbi
single game tied at three
mom and dad are happy their son has a
couple hits today and now at rbi mom
even noticed that dusty was holding
andrew up
maybe andrew thought there was a rock
paper scissors game that he missed
or maybe he just don't want to stop and
talk to dusty
beautiful piece of hit by alec though
just shooting everything up the middle
there the hard hit ball
split finger fast while the goldie
popped up
hit by the pitch
now the umpires will come together
we need to come together you're going to
get the warnings here what happened to
having just the home plate umpire
issuing the warning
get them on the bicep
above the pad we're not going to issue a
warning for that though here's a problem
when you do that though you just put the
winning run at first base sometimes you
got to do what you got to do you also
got to protect your best player yep
i mean there's no secret to that
there's some bark in there from the
cardinal dugout now mike schilt will be
ejected and has been
oh two pitch
and a high fly ball
[Music]
carlson gets in a position to throw
under it makes the catch runner tacks
throw into third double play
yes sir a strike to third
carlson
another outfield assist
kisner does his job and advances tyler
o'neill to third base with one down
good shot right here you should be
choking up a little bit you've got to
put this ball in play one two pitch
gets away here comes o'neil he will
score and the cardinals win it
a wild pitch and tyler o'neill scores
the winning run
it's a final in 10 innings the cardinals
win it 4-3